dès qu'ils ont appris que les recherches
étaient abandonnées tout change ils se
constituent en société sans chef au loin
un peu spécial leur seule règle survivre
ainsi le 29 octobre une avalanche tue
neuf survivants c'est le moment précis
où il commencent à manquer de vivre
fidèles à leur loi ils font alors
quelque chose de terrible ils se lient
par unacte d'anthropophagie pour
survivre ils mangeront les
morts à quel moment vous êtes-vous
décidé à manger de la chair
humaine
nous avons eu plusieurs conversations
entre nous et dès que nous avons su que
les vivres allent manquer nous avons
fait une réunion pour débattre du sujet
et nous avons tous été
d'accord quel
refusé au début quelques hés car il n'
pas l'habitude mais personne n'a refusé